[Musique]
m
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir nous
sommes en direct du stade pour assister
à la grande finale de football qui va
opposer l'équipe des oui à l'équipe des
oies les tribunes e son comble envahi
par une foule sympathique de supporter
les as en pots et les autres
naturellement son compte
du calme et on sera ducale
[Applaudissements]
le coup d'envoi est donné
un tueur magnifique aux nouvelles têtes
ah non les mains d'emma
la tire avec le pied en fait une tête
vendu joue pas avec les mains
et c'est reparti gage votre barre
rapidement balle au pied il est fauché
par un adversaire
[Applaudissements]
arbitre a eu raison de siffler on ne
doit pas faire de croche-pied
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le coup franc est tiré
[Applaudissements]
mais la balle est reprise par l'équipe
disent oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et aux messieurs du calme
ce n'est pas un match de boxe intentions
du calme
[Applaudissements]
et ça dégénère aussi dans les tribunes
quelle bagarre
[Applaudissements]
et finalement c'est credo chien qui
prend la balle pendant ce temps dans les
tribunes ça ne s'arrange pas oui
décidément ce n'est plus du football
c'est bien là la course à pied
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les petits bois tous fait un peu de
ménage
[Applaudissements]
ewa tour mais la balle au milieu
ouais
et avant le match écoutez wattmètre pas
demain pas de croche pied pas d'un coup
de poing
[Applaudissements]
deuxième mi temps
et on a pris trop de chiens pour un
ballot
[Applaudissements]
oui
faute puisqu'ils n'ont rien compris un
petit bois tout va prendre la place du
ballon
ouais
[Applaudissements]
et voilà ça peut apprendre à tricher
on ne touche pas la balle avec les mains
[Applaudissements]
allez maintenant c'est reparti très
sérieusement
une belle tête au fantastique
arrêté à temps
et match nul égalité zéro partout
l'arbitré siffle la fin du match c'est
le délit avant les crimes
et ces boîtes ou qui a gagné bravo à
tous à tous au revoir et merci
[Musique]
tous
et